l'apaisement Bruno milienne député MoDem
qui êtes avec nous ça passe par le
renoncement finalement du gouvernement
et de la majorité à cette réforme vous
êtes d'accord ou pas je sais pas si ça
passe par le renoncement que vous
demande en tout cas Fabrice chambellan
je pense que côté modem nous avons
essayé depuis le début de cette réforme
des retraites de maintenir le lien avec
la CFDT tout le monde sait que le modem
est assez proche de la CFDT même très
proche puisque nous avions porté
ensemble d'ailleurs la réforme de la
retraite par point en 2019 qui n'a pas
abouti malheureusement pour nous on va
dire puisque nous étions des ferments
partisans de cette réforme après
qu'Elisabeth borne prône l'apaisement
elle a raison parce que nous avons
énormément de travail à faire en commun
puisque en dehors de l'âge de départ
légal à la retraite qui a été retardée à
74 ans et qui est un problème pour
l'interphone ce que j'entends toutes les
revendications que vous entendez dans la
rue et tout est revendications légit
aussi l'Inter cervicale concerne surtout
l'organisation du travail
allez seniors qui n'ont pas de travail
c'est pas la retraite qui va améliorer
la situation des seniors c'est le
travail qu'on pourra faire ensemble les
carrières hachées si on veut les si on
veut les limiter c'est aussi du travail
qu'on va faire ensemble l'organisation
du travail parce que il y a un rapport
au travail aujourd'hui qui est
totalement différent de celui qu'il
était avant covid c'est chose que nous
devons discuter impérativement avec les
syndicat et en particulier avec la CFC
Bruno
c'est pas un problème de retraite
vous parlez de la suite pourquoi pas
suite non mais c'est important non mais
justement les deux sont liés peut-être
sauf que Elisabeth borne aussi aimerait
en parler avec les syndicats mais
fabrique chambellan vient de vous le
redire avant qu'on discute du reste il
faut renoncer au 64 ans
sauf que vous n'êtes pas prêt à le faire
Bruno millième
chose dans l'article 7 si on pouvait
s'entendre s'entendre là-dessus il y
aura une chose dans l'article 7 que nous
avons que nous avons tenu nos modèles
contrairement à ce que dit la presse
puisqu'ils attribuent ça auraient
républicain bref peu importe le chemin
est en le même admettons c'est cette
fameuse clause de revoyure en 2027
pourquoi en 2027 parce qu'en 2027 c'est
la fin de l'accélération de la loi
Touraine on arrive à 43 ennuités
pour avoir un plein temps à la retraite
et on avait posé cette clause de
revoyure pourquoi parce que d'ici à 2027
nous étions persuadés et nous le sommes
toujours d'ailleurs qu'en améliorant les
conditions de travail on pouvait se
retrouver en 2027 avec le conseil
avec le corps avec les organisations
syndicales à faire le compte du travail
qui avait été fait pendant quatre ans
voir s'il était encore nécessaire ou pas
de reculer cet âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans
que vous êtes d'accord le problème vient
d'Emmanuel Macron est dans Elisabeth
borne le problème le problème avec la
sfdt qui est pas un problème d'ailleurs
parce que franchement on est très proche
de syndicats oui mais Emmanuel Macron
non d'où ma question
Elizabeth band quand elle fait cette
déclaration hier elle a raison parce
qu'elle est au contact direct pour le
coup de
l'intersyndicaler il y a eu le président
lui il a aussi son avis mais c'est son
rôle aussi à Elisabeth borde de signaler
au président que elle est en contact
depuis des semaines et des semaines des
syndicats de l'intersyndical même s'il y
a pas eu de rencontres officielles on
sait qu'il y a eu des coups de
téléphones échangés elle elle elle est
directement en contact du terrain donc
finalement son appel c'est quoi c'est
effectivement de prévenir de mettre en
garde le président qui en Chine de dire
bon maintenant il faut peut-être qu'on
trouve quelque chose qui puisse apaiser
alors c'est vrai que
les positions sont assez lointaines les
unes des autres
les accords nous on a proposé une
médiation pourquoi on a proposé une
médiation parce que peut-être
le rôle d'un médiateur c'est déjà de
faire en sorte que deux personnes
parlent plus se parlent et sauf que le
gouvernement n'en a pas voulu oui je
sais bien le président n'en a pas voulu
mais nous on est dans notre rôle aussi
en tant que en tant que allié de la
majorité enfin en tant que
membre de la majorité de trouver des
solutions de sortie de crise après si
vous me permettez quand même et
j'aimerais aussi que l'Inter syndicale
puisse le reconnaître le régime notre
régime de retraite avant même qu'on
fasse cette réforme de retraite était
déjà très injuste on va pas dire le
contraire on l'a pas rendu plus injuste
il est un petit peu moins injuste je
prends les carrières longues par exemple
et tout le monde le sait bien avec la
loi Touraine c'était 45 ans de
cotisations avec ce qu'on a mis en place
et ce qui a été sorti de la commission
mixte paritaire ce n'est plus que 43 ans
c'est un exemple parmi tant d'autres qui
à peu près entre 6 et 7 milliards de
mesures sociales ça ne fait pas la
maille je suis d'accord ça ne fait pas
la maille beaucoup d'autres choses à
faire mais on peut quand même pas dire
que ce texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire et plus injuste que ce que
nous avons aujourd'hui sauf que ce qui
coin c'est l'âge de départ on en
reparlera avec vous deux pourquoi pas
Merci à VOUS Bruno million